today's been particularly crazy we had
on Monday following this this Mass
tragic incident the press secretary for
Katie Hobbs a Democrat post a photo of a
woman pointing to handguns saying what
we do when we see trans folks this
Democrat press secretary has now
resigned because that was outright a
declaration or some have viewed it as a
call to violence against their political
enemies
we got a lot more going on it's a it's
been a particularly crazy day Matt Walsh
was supposed to speak at a college
tomorrow but he's canceled due to
threats against him and his family we
obviously have the trans day of rage is
still going on and news breaking that
the group behind it recently had a gun
training and raised money to purchase a
bunch of weapons or at least I believe
that's what's being reported we'll get
in the full details and then strangely
a wave of school shooting hoaxes all
over the country and the calls came from
outside the United States so the initial
reporting that I heard was that it was
in Pittsburgh that numerous schools I
received phone calls about an active
shooter incident we saw videos online of
emergency vehicles rushing to the
schools then we heard it was happening
in other parts of the country as well
someone from outside the U.S started
making these phone calls something crazy
is happening and uh this weekend has me
particularly worried
so we're gonna get into all that but
before we do we have an awesome sponsor
we have Public Square head over to
publicsq.com and download the Public
Square app this is an app that shows you
businesses in your area or any area for
that matter who believe in American
values they believe in free speech they
believe in the family they believe in
personal responsibility so instead of
giving your money to companies that hate
you and funding Wellness inadvertently
you can download Public Square the app
open it up and find businesses in your
area that agree with your values so when
you when you buy from them you're
actually helping to fight the culture
War we're good friends the guys from
Public Square we're really excited we
had on the show a couple times and I
think this is one of the most important
apps in actually doing something about
the culture where we can't just complain
on the internet we can't just talk about
it though that's a good first step we
have to do something so for all these
businesses all around us that are simply
selling a product be it barbecue be it
shoes when they sign on to this app they
sign a pledge that they share your
values and you want to give them your
money instead of others so again public
square.com
publicsq.com a special shout out thanks
for sponsoring the show guys we're big
fans and I have also very big news you
may have heard last night cast brew
coffee has officially launched for
pre-orders your coffee will ship by May
5th which means it could be earlier but
we're setting that deadline for May 5th
because we are entering the production
of the beans and the bags and all the
product so head over to castbrew.com and
I recommend getting a rise with Roberto
Jr breakfast blend simply because I'm a
big fan of Roberto Jr he is our rooster
and then we also have the dark roast
Appalachian nights this was something
that uh I put together because I like a
good dark roast and it is a dark roast
but we also have a Colombian and French
roast available whole bean and ground
available castbrew.com and of course
become a member at timcast.com by
clicking join us become a member on the
Discord become a member on the website
get access to the Discord and you can
call into the after show we have a live
uncensored after show at about 10 10 P.M
Monday through Thursday and then we have
about four or so maybe five callers who
actually call in to talk to us and ask
questions if you would like to do that
sign up the minimum for that is six
months as a ten dollar member because we
have to have some kind of screening
process or you can sign up for 25 bucks
a month to get instant access to the VIP
chat where you can submit questions and
potentially be one of our callers for
the night
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a lot
more is Sean Spicer great to be back
yeah pleasure I think everybody knows
you but who are you and what do you do
for those that don't uh I host a show on
you smacks five o'clock every night I
just put out a brand new book called the
parrots Go Bananas it's available on
bravebooks.com talks about the ills of
fake news and you want to talk about a
great deal I mean you mentioned Public
Square these are guys who put out great
Christian patriotic books uh that that
speak to our values and they get to what
uh they allow kids to actually read
something as a father of two kids that
are 12 years old you want something that
you can have your kids that have
something that builds character that
talks about something that you can feel
comfortable as a parent knowing that
they're not being indoctrinated with and
you know I don't actually talk about
fake news in the book but it's something
that you can read to your kids and know
that they're dealing with issues that
that they're going to face as children
that they know how to do the right thing
so you know Brave books has been a great
partner to help educate kids they've got
great authors I was with Kirk Cameron
Jack Pacific the libs of tick tock
author Chaya today and we were out there
talking about with kids our books and it
was fun and this is what Brave books has
been all about so it's been fun to
partner with them it looks like the
allegory is that the parrots are the
referees and they may have gone crazy
well the parents are actually the bad
people in this book they actually are
are the they are helping to perpetuate
false news so they they that you've got
good characters in this book uh and they
are spreading bad news through this
system called tubular which is like
YouTube but we help the kids understand
the the what what happens if you spread
false information
um you know I I I've had I mean I know
you guys have all dealt with it or seen
it you talk about all the time I've been
accused of things uh I know a lot of
people have seen it dealt with it
themselves and so part of it was what
happens if you're accused of something
falsely but also and I think this is
like what I see with my kids a lot that
they're encouraged to pile on so it's
not always if you're the ones that are
accused because there's only a small
percentage of people that have that but
I think more likely than not you're
encouraged to join jump on the bandwagon
and that's where I wanted to write and
and because that's what kids deal with
it's like you know let's accuse this kid
of being the bad person and part of the
book is whoa slow down a moment let's
let's get all the facts first you know
think about a guy like Nick Sandman from
Covington Catholic who by the time all
the facts came out and all the video was
out the the Bell had been wrong and you
can't unring that Bell and I think part
of this and this is what we're talking
about today with these kids was let's
slow down don't judge let's presume the
good in people let's not try to go out
there and convict people before we have
all the facts and and that's what I
think we need to be teaching kids right
on so this should be interesting well we
have a lot to talk about we also have
Hannah Claire brimelow hanging out hi
I'm Hannah Claire brimwell I'm a writer
for timcast.com the book sounds awesome
well thank you and I'm Ian Crossland
from Ian crossland.net what's up and we
also have Serge duprea yes I'm muted
because I generally keep muted what's up
guys surge.com uh let's have a good show
let's jump into this first story now
this was uh this was this was difficult
because we have a couple big stories we
have Democrat press secretary for Katie
Hobbs Jocelyn Berry resigning but we
also had news earlier in the day from
Matt Walsh uh I think most of you know
who he is if you don't he is a prominent
conservative commentator he put together
the documentary along with the daily
wire crew and many others what is a
woman challenging gender ideology he was
supposed to speak at Washington and Lee
University but due to threat let me just
read the tweet for you he says sadly I
have to postpone my speech at Washington
and Lee University due to threats
against my family and other serious
security concerns in Nashville this week
I cannot leave my family and fly to
another state I hate to push the event
off but my wife and kids come first I
intend to continue my spring College
Tour as planned in the coming weeks the
event at Washington and Lee will be
rescheduled as soon as possible the
threats to my family only make me more
determined to fight this evil and will
not let any harm come to my children or
my wife and I will not let these
Psychopaths scare me into silence
neither of those things will ever happen
I promise you in case it wasn't clear
this has nothing to do with Washington
and Lee University the event was coming
together well and everything was
perfectly fine may have been some
protests planned but nothing major the
potential danger is at home which is why
I need to be at home so things are
getting absolutely crazy we have many
conservative commentators banned on
Twitter still for calling out this trans
day of Vengeance and it's a re it's
really weird I was thinking about this
earlier obviously we had this tragedy
that happened on Monday the psychopath
goes into a school slash Church kills
children and faculty members and then
what do we see there's a viral video
going around lives of tick tock posted
of a trans activist telling people to
get weapons and to go physically beat
people it's it's I've never seen
anything anything like this typically
when uh let's go back in time when we
had Andy know get attacked you actually
at the corporate press come out and be
like okay okay this goes too far now you
actually have the corporate press coming
out and saying well the real victims
here are the trans activists despite the
fact they're sending death threats to
the family of Matt Walsh and planning a
violent action a day of Vengeance
starting Friday into Saturday and Sunday
I call it a day of Vengeance but that
now they're saying it's gonna be three
days they're saying it's still going to
be happening but this is backwards I I
just don't understand this that it's
everybody else's fault that this
individual went out I mean right now the
the person that perpetrated this crime
and killed six people is being equated
to a victim what what what is going on I
I just I don't understand what has
happened in this country we are
literally less than 48 hours from a
major tragedy and somehow the mainstream
media has turned the person that
perpetrated this crime
taken six innocent lives into somehow of
a victim and when we're sitting around
having this debate and I just a mind my
mind is blown going what is going on how
old are you 51 51. so here's what I
think is happening
the older generation that was raised off
the internet
is they have a similar view of the
country be it left or right liberal or
conservative but the Millennials who are
raised online are hyper polarized yeah
so the reason why I think we're seeing
this happen is that Millennials are
starting to take over these industries
be it Media or otherwise and they are
hyper polarized their world is so
dramatically different from your world
as soon as they take the reins of the
editor editor-in-chief position or the
executive editor position start making
decisions on how articles get framed or
what stories get covered this is what
you start to see I know I think you're
right I mean that's that's exactly there
is this dichotomy in in the in the
country right now where young and old
see the world differently it's about
patriotism who views the country as
patriotic I mean the poll that came out
the other day in the Wall Street Journal
that that shocked the heck out of me 38
of the country views patriotism and I
literally you know a bunch of people I
knew said well I wasn't shocked at this
and I said you weren't shocked I I get
the division but there was something
that I thought United us and that was
being able to say okay I'm an American
and I mean maybe I didn't think it was
70 as I used to but I thought maybe it'd
be in the low 60s 38 and I think that
you put your finger on it Tim this idea
that there's a huge divide between
whether we grew up with the Internet or
without it and and that's and I I mean I
see it every day but it it's I don't
know maybe this is what's manifested the
the idea that you can see a tragedy like
this
and then say
here's the the person who perpetrated it
is also a victim and I was reading some
of the statements today and and from
some of these groups that you mentioned
earlier and they were like there are two
victims in this and I'm like no there's
not
yeah it is never acceptable you took out
innocent lives there's there's it makes
no sense why someone whatever the reason
may be would kill nine-year-olds yeah it
just doesn't make sense
any year olds what the leftist activists
are posting on Twitter is that they were
future fascists I'm not exaggerating
Andy no has covered this they are
posting that that there are people on
the left saying that's a good thing
because the future fascists were stopped
but this is this is the point you're 51.
when your demographic when Gen xers and
boomers are no longer in control of the
system either through retirement or
passing on this country will fall into
abject Civil War if we take this
seriously I mean if people are saying
crazy stuff online and we're like he
said he was a dog everyone look he's
said he was a dog oh no like don't it's
a terrible weak defense to say that this
person is a victim somehow sure
obviously they were drugged by someone I
mean that's in that way they were
victimized Ian the issue is the
corporate press is writing puff pieces
for this person it's not it's not about
and that's as Sean says unheard of it
but but this isn't look I get the
left-wing groups maybe or or the
left-wing media there was a piece in NBC
News Yep this isn't some Fringe
organization or some Fringe media piece
this is a one of the the three major
broadcast organization that is somehow
giving a a platform of sympathy to a
killer yeah yeah I think you have to
draw parallels to uh the relationship
between uh religious radicalization and
the online community you'll hear people
say I remember being taught this in
college that uh you'll have migrants
from move to you know France and they
are the first generation of their family
to go to school there but they don't
feel like they are French and they don't
feel like they are part of their uh
their Heritage they're not from their
country and so they look online for
acceptance and community and they're
more likely to become radicalized that
way and radicalization often calls for
violence to carry out your beliefs and
so this is something that I was taught
over and over again at my University uh
this is a pattern that we see with
people who are radicalized and it's the
same thing that's happening with people
who grew up in uh extreme gender
ideology they seek it out online they
feel uncomfortable they look for
community and the community says you are
being attacked at every turn and you
need to make sacrifices you have to be
willing willing to act on this I think
something that many conservatives and
many in the older generation haven't
asked themselves is when the people
these these Millennials and genziers who
hate this country
they hate it with a passion when they
start taking over companies what will
this country look like so a few years
ago Colin Kaepernick took a knee during
the national anthem and it was a
controversy within the span of only two
or so years every major sports team
every major athlete was told to take a
knee that is a culture Revolution
overnight and only now are that there
are there are athletes who are saying no
to this and they are the controversial
ones now think about that flip it is
going to keep happening because it this
is what I think people don't realize in
2015 Donald Trump starts running for
office
a child who is 10 years old will be
voting next 10 years old then who had no
understanding of politics their their
their developmental years is all being
raised by a media lying about Donald
Trump lying about the conservatives in
this country and the right and now
they're going to vote for the first time
in 2024. that degree of influence is
going to keep getting more and more
dominant and as gen x's and Boomers
retire and pass on give it 10 20 years
and you're going to have two different
factions in this country you already do
but here's the issue
among Millennials in gen Z the
bifurcation is clear far left extremists
are calling for more violence in
response to what happened on Monday
something would be shocking I mean we
wouldn't tolerate this 10 years ago
everybody would come out and be like
okay look man we know we have our
differences but this goes too far not
anymore and it's because the younger
generation is gaining more and more
power in Industry that's the natural
flow of things it has nothing to do with
people becoming radicalized it has
everything to do with young people
already being radicalized on these
platforms of course that's why we see in
schools these teachers trying to teach
critical race Theory and radical gender
ideology because they are trying to
indoctrinate them at a young age
they will grow up they plant those seeds
they put the glitter in the carpet that
never comes out and those kids don't
need any more guidance so give them 10
years it's done you know it's funny for
the longest time I had this belief that
one of the mistakes that conservatives
made was not going into high school and
colleges right and then I said part of
the problem is that students aren't
exposed to conservative ideas and
thinkers and then we see what's going on
I saw this myself I after I left the
White House I went to 20 college
campuses and I saw firsthand the idea of
getting shot at shadowed down right and
I know Matt is saying that part you know
he's not going to Washington Lee not
because of them but because of nothing
but the goal right now of the left is to
not allow
those voices to be heard whether it's
you know me and and all these authors
that Brave books to be able to go in to
talk to kids or people like Matt Walsh
and and some of the other folks to go to
college campuses the idea is to to not
allow these kids that you're talking
about who are going to vote to even know
that there is another point of view we
want to shut them out but the idea that
you're you're also talking about this
idea that these folks are talking about
violence
something that the left used to abhor
they're now talking about this this
weekend having these getting guns and
going out and getting people and again
where is the leadership from the top
saying this is unacceptable the
president United States has been asked
to comment two days in a row not only
has he joked about it but he hasn't
condemned the violence that the left is
talking about coming out and and seeking
retribution now because they're his
people exactly it's it's he you know I
don't think Joe Biden is like a staunch
leftist but he gains power from these
groups and they are willing to tolerate
him if it destroys the right that's why
many of these you had some prominent
leftists to make videos saying you got
to vote for Biden back in 2020 and it
was weird he's like a corporate
establishment politician but he's closer
to them so he knows he gets some benefit
from their politics which is why
Democrats Panda to them so what does he
care all right it works it works for him
right he's just a vessel he knows
did you hear about Merrick Garland
ordering uh uh Marshalls protesters
right because it benefits them right I
mean the funny part is when he gets
asked about this uh these slides they
were instructing the marshals he says I
don't know anything about it well you
were the guy that claimed just a while
ago that you were the ones who
instructed the marshals so on the one
hand whatever it was a year ago you're
claiming you were the one who ordered
them you had to give the order but when
it came to the instructions to the
marshals you knew nothing about that the
instructions it said let the protesters
do what they want I mean it's funny how
he only knows so much I want to jump to
the story from the Daily Mail
controversial group behind the trans day
of Vengeance raised money for firearms
training as other trans protesters pose
with guns ahead of March in DC on
Saturday now I want to make sure I State
this uh first and foremost they have a
right to Firearms they have a right to
firearms training and I do not care if
they want to go and March peacefully
while armed that his Second Amendment
right and in DC they don't allow it
which I think is wrong however we just
had a mass shooting
where a transgender individual wrote a
Manifesto these people defended it and
are now calling for a day of vengeance
this is as close to the line as you can
get there standing on wait just to be
clear the president of the United States
tweeted out the other day
when with respect to uh his court
hearing that people should go out and
protest and the left went nuts and said
how dare he call for protest with
respect to you know his this decision
that make him down about uh you know
from from the Manhattan district
attorney these folks are talking about
firearms training and I agree with you
they have a constitutional right to do
all of the aforementioned
but no one on the left they were they
went nuts and apoplectic that Donald
Trump was calling for people to protest
full stop just the word protest these
folks are talking about taking up arms
getting firearms training and no one on
the left seems to say a single word you
need to stop assuming you are in the
same country as these people they know
they hate you they know you are not a
part of their plan and their system so
when Joe Biden hears about Christians
being shot he laughed he laughed and
said I don't know anything about it you
know anything about it right three
nine-year-old children were gunned down
and he says I don't know about it and
they said Josh Hawley thinks they were
talking to Christians he goes well then
I probably think that I probably don't
agree yeah and I'm simply and I'm joking
yes I mean I'm joking about a tragedy
that six people just got killed like
that's I'm not sure what what's the
worst part about what you just said I
want you to imagine it this way
um what's your favorite sports team Sean
the New England Patriots New England
Patriots have they played against
anybody recently or what's what's the
most recent uh game they played well it
would have been last season last season
yeah uh name another team you don't like
the Jets the Jets and they play against
each other I'm not big on Sports It's
both in the AFC East all right all right
so uh um tell me the tell me the teams
again it's the Patriots versus the Jets
Patriots versus the Jets so you are
watching the Jets
get get uh was it football yep they get
through a touchdown and it's a
controversial call are you gonna cheer
for them no not for the Jets exactly and
you're going to be angry and outraged
but let's say there's a controversial
call that benefits your team are you
gonna defend them
no of course I mean the benefits the
Patriots Yeah it's a controversial call
it's not like it's definitive one way or
the other you're gonna say my team
should get it sure and then when they
get no no no no I'm gonna challenge that
what's happening right now in the United
States is that
the Democrats have been doing this for a
long time they they will uh Joe Biden
for instance will engage in a quid pro
quo with Ukraine saying if you don't
fire the prosecutor not getting a
billion dollars when we say hey you guys
broke the rules they start laughing you
think we're playing a game with you we
don't care about that we can get away
with whatever we want but we will wield
those tools against you that's what
they're doing so unfortunately for us
the refs are on the Jets side right now
oh yeah the refs the commissioner the
corporate response I mean that's the
thing is it's one thing to say the refs
are with you they got the league they
got the corporate sponsors they got the
guys who build the field and so when you
are sitting there and they keep throwing
out controversial calls and giving the
other team the the touchdown
conservatives Independence and and
dispected liberal types Libertarians
just keep going oh come on ref well you
know we'll get them next time what are
you talking about they're all laughing
behind your back these protesters go out
to the home of Supreme Court Justice
illegally you can't do this and Merrick
Garland says do not arrest them
and then you get some woman who took a
picture in DC on January 6th they raid
her home in Alaska even though she
wasn't in the building
this has been going on for some time
pro-life pro-life activists get their
homes rated these people get protection
I I'm telling you I just I
I see I don't see it going any other way
it is happening right before our eyes we
hadn't we had in Wisconsin these BLM
activists set fire to a house twice
and then when that same group showed up
in front of another guy's house he
brandished a firearm inside his house
feeling threatened and the police came
and arrested him oh no this is they went
into his house and took him and the BLM
activist cheered for it they cheered for
the police
I think the the thing that folks on the
right have got to start understanding in
my opinion is that this idea that that
there's a that to I mean this goes to
exactly what you're saying that somehow
that we've that it's a Level Playing
Field and then we've just we've got to
start playing by their rules and and
saying fine then we'll go out and fight
and like this is where we've got to
Define their like everyone wants to play
nice and nice right so for example right
now the Republicans are going through
this debt ceiling thing why are we not
defunding everything on the left this
idea that somehow it's got to be a like
let's play nice with them and figure out
we control the house the house controls
the first string start defunding things
stop pretending that this is uh that we
need to get along and get along they
they do fun stuff on the right like this
is there are some this level of
collegiality that we believe that
they'll treat us like like if they get
back in power that's just never gonna
happen but but so the challenge I
suppose then is
if if this is the direction everything
is going regardless of what we want to
happen What happens in five or ten years
here's my point if we don't recognize
what you're talking about that the fight
is on that they are going after they're
going in I mean I was at this Library
this morning to talk about
wholesome things about patriotism about
being a good person right and the
library a DC Public Library put up pride
and trans flags all over it right to
that was their counter like I saw those
photos right and this was like we
weren't there to I there was no
anti-trans anti-pride there was no this
wasn't about any like any message that
was against anybody it was literally
here's a message about being a good
person there the fight is on we either
are willing to to go out there and and
engage
or they're gonna win what they're doing
right now is overt acts of violence
death threats terrorism in Atlanta they
fire bombed a government facility they
burn down houses they burned uh I
flipped over a guy's truck and
conservatives are barely mustering up
speaking events Matt Walsh was forced to
cancel a speaking event over death
threats meanwhile they are calling for
violence this weekend they're out there
look at this firearms training I mean
they're going out there doing this and
not one media organization will report
on this tonight Hunter Biden takes what
1.5 million dollars and and we get and
people on the right get accused of
making up stories well there are but my
point is Hunter's a prodigy painter of
course well he does those are very
beautiful but the point is is that at
some point
we've got to start understanding that
that the corporate media and everybody
else they're not going to give us a fair
shake so go out there and and stop
pretending this idea that I mean I saw a
story today on the way here Chris
Christie won't support Donald Trump if
he's the nominee stop it do you think
that they said that when John fetterman
was the nominee in Pennsylvania or Joe
Biden was the nominee this is this idea
on the right that we're all this purity
test give me a break I'll vote for any
Republican that's the nominee to go
against Joe Biden there is I mean stop
this nonsense I I just think
it doesn't matter what we do
the millennial and gen Z generations and
younger are hyper-radicalized
hyperpolarized and the only thing
stopping overt and direct conflict is
that Gen X and boomers are still in
control at the highest level of
Institutions but we've got a good 10 or
20 years left before they're not and
then when you get Disney run by woke
leftists and their entire world view is
solidified and they think you're a Nazi
we're already seeing what happens with
Merrick Garland in control of the doj he
says protect the people breaking the law
that benefit us and prosecute those that
even step anywhere near the line that
oppose us yeah so where are we going to
be in 10 years it's going to be worse
well it depends on what you do for the
next 10 years if I I think we should not
firstly do not engage people in violence
directly because that's like there's
this metaphor fighting an alligator
underwater you don't want to fight it
under water yeah don't do that do not
fight them in a place where they want
you to fight them in it's not the way
but I always spent like four hours last
night listening to music and realized
again for the first time again that the
key moving forward is to create the
culture is to make massive Ripple
effects and inspire people and make
people come together for something other
than
hate something other than stress and I
think that's the way forward I think the
most powerful thing people can do right
now to try and reverse things and and
protect this country is start a business
make money have a family
get some chickens maybe get away from
cities I think the family and money
thing is the most important it's Mike
cernovich who's been saying this for a
long time because if you plant those
seeds right now you build personal
wealth you build a business you have a
family in 10 years we won't have to
worry about the levers of control right
can I just make one point though because
you know you called up my age here I uh
I don't want to speak for Hannah Claire
but I mean I as a father as someone here
I assume like I
I I sit around sometimes with parents
and all all their kids will have phones
and I'll be like they're like oh you
know these kids with the influences and
I'm like you're the one who handed the
kid a phone yeah you're the one who put
the kid on Tick Tock don't tell me that
you're upset about the influences that
you can have you let them have Snapchat
you let them have Tick Tock you gave
them a phone and now you're complaining
I'm sorry my kids are 12 and I don't I
didn't give them a phone I don't allow
them on Tick Tock and I think that at
some point be a parent yeah I think the
phone argument it's the phone it's the
Kindle it's the iPad it's the TV I said
this one's on the show but I think
having a TV in your home is like asking
a stranger off the street to come
babysit your kids right especially cable
TV you don't know what's going to come
up on anything you don't know what uh
video YouTube is gonna put on next after
the one that you put on for your kid
that you think is innocuous you don't
know what any of the algorithms that
your teens are looking at is going to
generate for them and that is so
incredibly dangerous but Tim you you
you're talking about you know having a
fan family and going to a farm I mean
but part of this is and I agree with all
that right but in some cases it's it's
possible in some cases it's not but I
would say regardless of whether you
could move out and and you know get a
piece of land which is I think a lot of
people would love to do it but some
cases it's not possible but when not
engage with your kids find out what
they're learning I mean the one great
thing about covid is that kids sat at a
kitchen table in a lot of cases and
parents said this is what you're
learning this is what you're reading and
they actually were able to have some
discussions but I just you know I I I I
think that too many times YouTube is
substituting for a babysitter or
substituting for parenting or or your
neighbors I think that the core the
family is the nuclear building block of
society right but you should know your
community as well right that's one of
the reasons I love coming into an office
I know the people I work with I know
what's going on with their life I think
we could all be better about knowing
what the other people on our street or
in our building I mean you're right not
everyone can move to a farm but you
could know your neighbor if you could
know them better you could build a
relationship with them especially if
they are the people living next door to
you right it's one thing to follow in an
influencer because maybe you're
interested in something they're working
on whatever else but you can't let those
parasocial bonds uh replace the Real
Life Connections you can have with
people I want to I want to jump to the
story from the post millennial and we'll
get into the hard politics of this
um we have this story Katie Hobbs press
secretary resigns in disgrace after
posting threat of violence against quote
transphobes on Twitter and the important
bit here is that the post was made
Monday night well after everyone already
knew the motivation of the of the show
well I presumed motivation of the
shooter the identity of the shooter and
that there was a Manifesto police had
stated that they believe the identity
played a role in the motivation and then
she posted a photo it says us when we
see transphobes and it's a picture of a
woman holding two handguns and clearly
pointing them at someone many people saw
this as a direct call for violence and
the crazy thing is Tucker Carlson did a
segment about this last week where he
said these people want to get guns he
was talking about trans activists taking
up guns in the threat of violence and
then sure enough only that he was
roasted for it that left attacked him
for it then come Monday we get this this
woman posted this photo and left it up
for days
she she did not take this down it was it
was taken down by Twitter
I do not believe she would have taken it
down or resigned unless she absolutely
had to because his borders on criminal
activity borders on I don't think she
created information that is a clear and
present threat but based on the call to
the trans day of Vengeance and what
happened on Monday she's basically there
already
I think these people you saw what
happened with the Covington kids you
brought up Nick Sandman they called for
the death of children
all because a video emerged showing a
Native American banging a drum in his
face that's all it was when I saw that
video everyone's like wow Tim you got to
see this video say something about it
and I was like what is there to say I
don't know what happened it's a kid with
a guy banging a drum in his face and
they're like yeah but look at that kid
look what he's doing I'm like what is he
doing he's standing there sure enough I
found the live stream that showed the
Native American man walked up to the kid
and banged the drum in his face and I'm
like why are y'all mad at the kid they
one guy posted a picture of a wood
chipper with blood coming out of it one
one guy I think it was Reza Aslan said
the kid was punchable these people are a
zombie mob they would not apologize and
take this down unless they were forced
to do so and when all that went down
many of them didn't they were calling
for the death of children with not they
didn't care about the facts they didn't
care about what was true and the media
lied to defend the mob this is why I'm
really worried especially about this
weekend because I can't see this going
in a positive direction not not in the
in the short term
I I mean
that we're getting to a Tipping Point
and that's what I think worries me is
that what what is acceptable right that
that
do they you know what what sort of act
of violence uh because this would have
normally gotten complete outrage uh the
idea that this is happening you talking
about it is probably the extent that
we're going to see of it it doesn't make
ABC News it doesn't make the Washington
poster the New York Times well I can't
guarantee if this was if this if you
take out Katie Hobbs and you write Glenn
Younkin or Ron DeSantis Lester Holt's
leading with this tonight let's go back
to the sports uh metaphor or analogy if
you went to a bar surrounded by everyone
wearing the same Jersey and said
something disparaging about the Jets
everyone's gonna laugh
No One's Gonna Go hey look man look it
goes a little too far there may be a
different team but we're all just trying
to be friends they'd be like yeah and
they'd high five you right they don't
care when you insult the opposing team
the only problem is
a friendly sports game it's fun to have
that kind of rivalry and and and it's
it's almost sometimes it gets out of
hand you know especially with soccer
hooligans and stuff but the the the the
Hokey like my team is better than yours
is is all in good fun and we want our
teams to win the problem with this is
they're telling everyone it's life or
death they're saying the right wants to
commit a genocide well that level of
rhetoric is the it's in the real world
and these are people who have guns and
are doing firearms training now what we
saw on Monday
they've been planning for things like
this these far left extremists but the
thing that I find funny too is it's the
opposite right I don't really care I
mean to be honest with you like my my
view has always been and I think
generally speaking people on the right
are like hey go live your life I don't
really care right I mean that's
generally people on the right generally
are like laissez-faire about what you
want to do with your life it's the
people on the left that are the most
intolerant they they preach tolerance
but they're the ones who actually want
to come out and attack people on the
right they they love to preach about
this idea of Tolerance but their idea of
tolerances agree with me about being
tolerant it's hard for me not to wonder
if this sort of you're right it won't
get picked up everywhere but a fair
number of people have talked about this
this tweet and how it seems just
obviously inappropriate uncalled for uh
completely insensitive it makes me
wonder uh Independence how they'll react
to it people who sort of not very
political they might lean a little bit
left they might lean a little bit right
but watching the the ground beneath them
shift and totally split they're gonna
have to make a decision on which side
they fall and I can't say that this is
enticing anyone to think highly of of
Katie Hobbs obviously it's not her
official account it wasn't from her it's
just someone who was in her
Administration I think these moments
where you have uh people siding with
someone who literally murdered children
and three adults you know it it comes
down to the independent voters what are
they going to do they're probably going
to side many of them like cowards with
whoever's in power but I think but but
my point is this if there if if that if
they're never presented with that choice
and that's what I would argue is that if
you walk down the street tomorrow in any
place they're going to say I didn't hear
about this I mean I would say this all
the time when I used to work at the RNC
and I'd call a reporter up and say hey
when I used to I'd get a call and say
like little Tommy at you know Jefferson
Middle School did the filing bad with
what's the rnc's position right we get
called for everything and then some
prominent Democrat would do something
outrageous Arabic did you guys call the
DNC for comments every Washington Post
New York Times oh we didn't even know
that that occurred like how did you not
know this Nancy Pelosi is the you know
minority leader speaker of the house
whatever positions yet well we didn't
hear about it so they'd never report on
these things so I guarantee you the
problem is that this is my point that
the that no one in the middle is going
to hear about this because the NBC News
is in the Washington Post aren't going
to report on it so the person in the
middle isn't going to even know that it
occurs except moderates do consume some
conservative media people a lot of
people watch this show that are in the
middle yeah well and that's again
there's I'm not saying that enough
people but the majority of Americans
when they wake up tomorrow morning and
watch you know Good Morning America The
Today Show or CBS it's not going to pop
up there whereas if it was a Glenn young
or a Ron DeSantis or Christy gnome
they'd see it you know you mentioned um
tolerance earlier and how the left and
the liberal mind used to be the tolerant
the side of Tolerance and then I because
I used to be like that I'm like accept
everybody everybody's cool whatever and
then you get these kind of these
behaviors of intolerance that come in
and you're like well I'll tolerate it
because I'm tolerance and then the
system starts to become intolerant I'm
like am I supposed to not tolerate
intolerance because then I'm the
intolerant one and and then what then
I'm the villain it's like that that
music video Tim that you did Will of the
people like am I supposed to say no this
villain is a villain and I do not
tolerate it then I become the villain
like at what point where's the balance
this is what your personal values are
right like you shouldn't tolerate things
that fly directly in your face I love
the idea of let everyone Live and Let
Live but in reality that's impossible to
do unless you have a common set of
values so you're coming to the adult
realization of conflict in where there
is no end point there is no position of
absolute moral Authority so you take a
look at what the left does they seem to
operate not on principle but on
Collective Vision if the zombie horde of
the left deems it so they do it even if
it's hypocritical to their previous
stance you see this with we talked about
the other day other day uh Brett brought
it up defiant elves where um that that
Dash guy posts you know this is why the
Republicans want to get rid of the FBI
and then a few months later he's like we
should completely get rid of the FBI
like there's no there's no logic other
than does it benefit me or not and so
the issue is one one thing that I've
talked about
people need to understand is
here's the question should parents have
final say in whether or not their
children receive a medical treatment
would you say yes or no 100 so then what
about the parents that want to give
their kids sex changes
should the government then intervene and
stop them from doing so I think below 18
uh I mean if it's a life-altering
well change my point is simply this the
left argues parents should have a final
say in their child's development only if
it pertains to their ideological value
then when it comes to the uh you know
parents who are trying to stop the kids
from undergoing this to say the parents
are abusing the kids and the kids should
be protected by the state thus in
Washington children underage can go to a
doctor and get sex changes without their
parental consent right so the issue is
both sides are saying the same thing but
clearly one side is right well I think
their morality is based upon
collectivism and not principle our
morality is based on principle and not
collectivism and so my view is yeah
miners can't consent to these things
however the challenge then becomes we
actually do think there is a point where
the government should intervene and tell
a parent no you cannot give your child
this medical treatment but I mean think
about it if I mean so because if you
take that if one were to take that view
and a parent came in and said my
religion believes you need to have your
left arm cut off we'd say no you'd say
no because that's insane like so so and
again if you believe that below a
certain age that you are altering a body
to a to to do something that has well
this is my point your moral position
is not simply parents have final say a
lot of conservatives kept saying this
they kept saying parents should
determine what's right for their kids so
Rhonda Santos was correct to pass the
parental rights and education Bill and
then my response was okay and if the
parent wants to give their child a sex
change no no no not then then the
government should intervene and it's
like okay so you do think there are
instances where the government should
intervene based on your morality now I
agree with you I think yes I think we
are correct children can't consent and
they shouldn't be getting these things
but the left in Washington has an
inverted world view where they think
children should be able to go to a
doctor without their parents knowing and
get these treatments based on the same
logic that there that the government
should intervene if parents are abusing
their kids so we think a parent who
wants to give a kid a sex change is
that's abuse and the government should
stop them for them in Washington they
think a parent who blocks a kid from
getting sex changes abusing their kid
and the government should be able to
stop them they're both arguing the same
sentence with a different it's like
Scott Adams says it's one screen
but two different movies being played to
two different groups of people that's
why I'm like I I don't see how you're
going to be able to go to those people
and convince them but anyway back to
what you were saying Ian my point is
this that's why the statues rotate and
there's always a new villain when for
Frozen don't know the reference we
produced a music video several years ago
where these people are pulling down a
statue and it's a wheel a new Statue
comes up when one Statue gets pulled
down and then they pull the next one
down and another one comes up
there's a new Statue every time when
group a gets their leader put in Power
Group a doesn't revolt against him the
next Revolution is from Group B
Group B tears down the statue of command
of Captain a and then Group C protests
Group B
so if you get a Donald Trump in power
it's not like one day Trump supporters
go out and Stage a revolution no the
Trump supporters are happy with Trump
it's the left that comes out in stages
the culture Revolution then when they
put Biden in it's the Trump supporters
that try to remove so that's why there's
always going to be the cycling this
wheel at cycling but as we develop a two
generations of Youth hyper polarized you
are you are setting the stage for an oh
outright Civil War you know I think
there is a potential outline silver
outline to this the very good outcome to
this is is that I I kind of agree with
you Sean about I think if it's a
life-altering surgery for a minor that
maybe there should be some oversight of
what a parent's going to do to a kid
but I don't think that it's up to us to
stop them from doing it I think it's the
kids that are getting changed that are
becoming adults and realizing what did
they do to me and now they're speaking
out there that was like like Chloe Cole
and people that have been through this
and are like I will sue these companies
and maybe people will sue their parents
I don't know how it's going to come out
but I think that generation of people
are going to be the ones that speak up
and speak out to others that have are
going through it as 13 year olds or
nine-year-olds or whatever yeah I I'm
when we're talking about this I keep
thinking about this case from Canada
where uh uh I think she was like 14 year
old girl
um was a Jehovah's Witness and she was
diagnosed with lymphoma and she needed a
blood transfusion and that went against
the doctrines of her religion and she
was like I'm not going to get it this is
what my family believes I don't want to
go through this and ultimately a court
in Canada intervened and ordered her to
go through the treatments she would have
died from lymphoma is what they say
without the treatment and the treatment
would have saved will have saved her uh
it's this very strange line between did
she have the right to refuse it when she
could have been saved are we infringing
on her religious rights she's 14 she's
it's different than like a six-year-old
but she's still not an adult at what
point do we say there are some things
that we do to protect your life so that
you can become a full adult and make the
decisions on your own exactly I'm living
in a naturopathic medicine that
terrifies me that I would think I know
you have to take the pharmaceutical
under court order that's ridiculous like
you need you need diet and exercise and
sunlight those things are like the basis
of health so I don't like that but
there's not really a naturopathic answer
to the the gender question right like
that would be like maybe go to therapy
and talk about it with someone and wait
until you're older to intervene but with
transgender issues there it has to be
medical intervention it has to be
surgical it could be diet too like
stress if they're drinking a lot of
Pepsi when they're no offense Pepsi if
they're drinking a lot of sugar when
they're a little kid that could tweak
them out make them go crazy uh if
they're getting Adderall when they're
nine like that's the dietary also
believe yes you are born in the wrong
body and we need to intervene it's not
like they're going to be like so stop
drinking Pepsi and that'll cure that you
know like there are some issues where uh
people's personal convictions conflate
against what actually might be the
safest route you know what I'm saying
yep yeah okay well let's jump to the
next story
we have this from the New York Post U.S
Marshals told not to arrest abortion
protesters at scotus justices homes U.S
Marshals assigned to protect Supreme
Court Justices Holmes following the
reversal of Roe v Wade last year were
directed not to arrest protesters unless
absolutely necessary according to newly
revealed documents Senator Katie Britt
unveiled a series of training slides
used to prepare Marshals for their
assignments as she grilled attorney
general Merrick Garland at a senate
appropriation subcommittee hearing
Tuesday the slides instructed the
marshals to avoid unless absolutely
necessary any criminal enforcement
involving protesters and that making
arrests and initiating prosecutions was
not the goal of their being stationed
outside the residence of the Court's six
conservative jurists so I think uh plain
as day you can see it right there
someone showed up trying to kill
Kavanaugh and his family they said
outright no no no no enforcement let him
go let them do their thing it's illegal
by the way and the reason it's illegal
is that I believe it was in the 50s they
said judges are not elected officials or
these at least in the same way and if
judges cannot be free from political
pressures there is no justice because
that's how the court system works so
they said in this instance no protesting
judges
these people are now doing it the left
is defending it someone tried to kill
this man and Merrick Garland is saying
you're free to keep breaking the law
where's where's where's the but then he
did the Republicans right yeah exactly
and that was the problem is that it it
took this long too to figure it out why
why I mean you know it would have been
nice if your Kavanaugh or his family to
know this like a few months ago when it
was happening but the idea that that
Merrick Garland stood there today and
kind of denied that he had any insight
into this happening there are training
materials Katie Brett the senator from
Alabama is literally posting up these
slides saying here's what the shows and
he's like I have no idea that's a bad
sign for him like why would you say I
have no idea what these people who are
but they're directly in my chain of
commanders there's a level there's a
point at which you're either incompetent
or lying but it's one of the two
which one is it I mean you either don't
know what's happening in your department
because because think about this isn't
like hey did you know about the guard at
the front gate right uh you know I
didn't know okay well there's 18 doors
and there's a bunch of buildings these
are Supreme Court Justices that are
being threatened and you're the guy
that's saying I'm going to send U.S
Marshals to augment the security at some
point wouldn't you know about the what
they call the Rules of Engagement like
hey what are you telling these guys yeah
and what information was given to the
justices can you imagine being Brett
Kavanaugh and saying you know shouldn't
I be able to move my family out of the
area I mean if you don't think
protesters are going to
be I mean what's the point you're just
going to station there so the protesters
can be outside terrify the family
potentially get more raucous it could
get more dangerous and you're going to
say that well we're going to avoid
arresting them for as long as possible
like you're not really protecting them
it's because they're dealing with their
children Merrick Garland was supposed to
be on the Supreme Court at least that's
what he's probably thinking so he's
probably smiling and laughing as well
he's also pissed about the decision well
of course right he's like you know what
you want to vote against Roe you know
what I'm not having your I don't have
your back well he's thinking it should
have been me yeah it should have been me
and I wouldn't have this wouldn't have
happened he's probably sitting there so
he's laughing they deserve this yeah
like that's craziness I mean come on
these people are clearly insane you know
so he's the I imagine he's sitting there
laughing about this being like you
shouldn't have been there in the first
place it's your own fault this is so
horrible I have something I want to say
that I'm not comfortable saying on
YouTube it's so dark this is so
ridiculous I'm going to write it down
and talk about on the after show
here's the other thing that I would just
say that is interesting because
this this has started to you know
whether or not it's it's a Supreme Court
Justice
it's a government official it's a member
of Congress you talked about that
there's a point at which people start to
say I'm not running for office I'm not
serving I'm not speaking out I'm not
whatever it is there's a level of which
this is not worth it anymore and and you
talk Matt Walsh speaking out Brett
Kavanaugh serving in as a supreme court
and you know so and so running for
office so-and-so serving in the in the
government at some point you say this
isn't I'm gonna shut up whether serious
or not there have been people who have
been like Tim you should run you should
run and my response is I could not
imagine having all of the problems of
Fame and none of the money it's like if
you want to be in office in politics I
think you're nuts because Kavanaugh
makes what like 270 000 a year and he's
got people outside his home threatening
his family's life one guy tried to kill
him and his family and I'm like man so
you must really want that job and really
believe in it to to live that way I mean
not just that look at the lies they
spread about people like Matt Gates do
dude's not making a whole lot of money
doing this I'm surprised there are
people who want Donald Trump lost money
his his taxes only showed that as
president he was losing money and still
giving away his salary it's amazing they
were like once we get his tax return
we're going to prove oh he was losing
money haha he lost money it's like so
you're saying he made a huge personal
sacrifice to be president come on spare
me at the very beginning of this story I
missed a part of what you were saying
about what mayor Garland says he didn't
know which was These Guys these six guys
uh orders is that what it was no they so
the there's these slides come out today
Katie Brett the center from Alabama
while he's at the subcommittee basically
puts up a series of trading slides that
they were given to the U.S Marshals
right and the training slides
are basically saying don't don't arrest
these protesters as they engage with
these Supreme Court Justices as they I
mean Tim's pointing out like it's
illegal what the if you go protest at
their houses okay and there should be
arrested and the training sides are like
hey hands off guys don't don't do it
just let them be on their way right
telling cops not to enforce the law and
then Merrick says and the cop said you
got it buddy don't worry these cops I
gotta tell you man this is where you get
me right up to the to the defund the
police abolish the police and we've
talked about it before these are the
people who will pull you over for the
from Myron fraction and say tell it to a
judge and give you no leeway these are
people that shut down businesses during
covid and and arrested men and women for
simply trying to sell coffee and then
when they're witnessing something
overtly illegal on the books they are
told by superiors don't arrest them can
I tell you this you got it but but I
will say this I haven't talked to a lot
of buddies of mine in law enforcement
they this is the stuff that irks them
that they're like my hand like I want to
do my job I cannot like the the this
they didn't get into law enforcement to
stand there they could arrest them they
if that's what they're told they can't
they can't
uh well I mean then they get then they
immediately in New York City there are
police officers there's this funny story
where this morbidly obese older woman
walks around with no shirt on and in New
York it's legal for women to be topless
because of uh equality ruling in the
courts and there are cops who know she's
allowed to do it they don't care they
arrest her anyway they say man put a
shirt on she goes no no we're arresting
you because in their mind and then she
Sues and she wins every time she's done
a bunch of times it's a ridiculous story
the problem is these cops are cowards
they're absolute cowards and nothing
will convince me otherwise there is
these are the kind of cops that are like
they they instructed me to shoot the dog
or they told me I had to arrest the old
lady I have no choice but to violate the
rights of people because someone else
told me to do it I look forward to if if
it ever comes down to hearings on
coveted lockdown and and and the
violations of law we're having these
cops come in and firing them and
stripping them of their pensions and
saying now you can live in a cardboard
box because you thought it was prudent
to ignore your oath to uphold the law
because your political boss told you not
to enforce it I won't play those games
and we need a politician maybe it's not
going to be a politician we need an
elected official who's the first thing
they do is they call in the federal
police officers and they say which one
of you did not enforce the law all of
you you're all fired and I'm gonna say
to it your family never sees a
penny and they go oh but but I was told
just not to enforce the law and let far
far left extremists go in front of just
judges homes and and threaten their
lives well that's too bad for
you These Guys these cops need to be the
first in line to feel the punishment
because as long as these cops are
allowed to keep breaking the law
ignoring the law or enforcing fake laws
the system is completely broken when I
see salon owners get arrested under
unconstitutional edict when I see
churches shut down and police officers
enforcing the shutdown of churches in
violation of the Constitution with Cuomo
saying even though the Supreme Court of
New York ruled against me saying I'm not
allowed to do this I'll just create
another executive order and do it anyway
you know why because these
cops will absolutely enforce edict from
these Executives even if it's against
the law because no one will go to them
as individuals and say I will destroy
you for enforcing this people
keep making excuses for the cops who are
doing this and if it's not the cops it
doesn't have
if there were no police officers there
would be no unconstitutional lockdown if
there were no cops there would be no
churches shut down during covid and
everyone gave them a free pass when the
cops went to that gym attilis in New
Jersey and arrested the people people
outside of it or or I think the owners
got huge fines got shut down everyone's
like well I don't blame the cops they're
being told to do it no no I blame them
twice as much now because the worst
thing the cops the cops could have done
what they can do they can say if you're
telling me to not enforce the law I will
not show up I will not swear enough to
uphold the law in the Constitution and
then have you tell me to break that out
but these are oath Breakers these are
pieces of human trash I have no respect
for them at all and if it were up to me
and if I was ever in office and I would
I would request this right now and I
know no one's going to do it because our
politicians are all cowards I'm giving
no no respect and no benefit to any
Republican because none of them will do
it I want them to take a single officer
from that photograph get their name
plaster it in Congress and say I am
coming for you I am going to take from
you your pension and your retirement and
I want your family to know it's because
you refuse to uphold the law if you come
into this office if you put on that
badge and say outright it's someone
else's fault I won't do my job I will
make sure you lose everything because if
you don't want to do your job this job's
not for you you can resign right now no
one's going to do it no one's going to
do it conservatives are going to keep
looking the boots of these cops who who
bashed them over the head during coven
and who refuse to enforce the law to
protect our justices if the judges can't
issue rulings because they're under
threat of death there can be no justice
and these cops are going but it's not my
fault I was told not to enforce the law
okay then get out fire them rant over if
if a cop's Superior Officer says today
we're going to violate the law and the
cops like no I'm not and then they go
and they arrest the guy anyway is it is
it a legal arrest because the superior
officer said it's don't arrest them but
the lower rank did it it's still legal
arrest police officers can arrest you
a cop can walk up to you on the streets
of New York put you in cuffs bring you
in they don't got to read you your
rights or do anything now later on there
will have to be some kind of
justification for the arrest and often
you'll get civil suits when far left
extremists staged an Insurrection at
Donald Trump's inauguration and set
vehicles on fire set fires in the
streets and smashed windows up the city
ended up paying them
the government DC tried charging the far
left extremist with conspiracy because
they all wore black and the courts ruled
you cannot charge a group you need to
tell us which individual broke the law
and because you can't they're free to go
and you violated their rights and paid a
multi-million dollar settlement to the
extremists
so when I see this I see pathetic
feckless cowards and the only way this
stops is when these cops say with all
due respect Superior officer there is
nothing you can instruct me to do that
will stop me from enforcing the law I
think law in the book says they can't do
it I will arrest them on site you got a
problem with that put me somewhere else
what and then what happens when no cops
show up at all what happens when they
say either we enforce the law or we will
not stand in front of these homes
because you realize what these cops are
being told to do right they're being
told to stand in front of a building
where people are threatening death
against these justices and they are told
you can do nothing to stop them nothing
you can't arrest them unless absolutely
necessary okay so there's some leeway
there these cops should all walk away
and say assign us somewhere else we are
not gonna We're Not Gonna We're not
gonna try and protect a house with our
hands tied by our backs but they're all
cowards they are all cowards there's
very few good cops many of them resigned
almost all of them are cowards and
they're like you don't understand my
boss won't let me do it if I was a cop
and I was in front of that house I'd
walk right up to the lead organizer and
say put your hands behind your back and
I would arrest them on the spot and then
I would say I will get fired before I
let you do this but these cops won't do
it because they're cowards meanwhile
there's a woman who opened a cafe in
Minnesota and then they threatened her
with the rest and sheriffs and the
deputies hunted her down in Iowa found
her and arrested her a salon owner in
Texas got arrested and it was only
because I think Abbott intervened she
got released in New Jersey we saw the
attila's gem get shut down these
lockdown orders were unconstitutional
and illegal and the police with smiles
on their faces shut these businesses
down it's important what you're saying
it is because this is what happened in
Nazi Germany is there's this argument of
we were just following orders it's very
amazing look
I will say this if
it is an element of the people who are
telling them not to do it
are are ultimately the ones that I
that need to be held accountable more
than anything else well sure but like if
if a mob boss instructs his henchmen to
go rob a bank do we just say well no no
no no no no no but of course not and
that's who gets ultimately but but at
some point in that's why there's like a
RICO statue that goes after the guy at
the top but at some point it is these
guys and that's what you can't like
we're we're letting off somebody a mayor
you know in the case of of of these of
the gym in New Jersey or the county
commissioner or somebody said shut that
Jim down or shut that church down these
are the people that we should name names
for though more than anything else if we
want to disagree oh if we start a list
that's where it starts if if a mayor or
a governor stands on top of a giant
Stone and says I hereby call upon all of
my officers to shut down businesses and
all those officers look at him and go go
yourself
nothing happens the words are
meaningless but at some point
the and again I like we are a a country
of laws that mayor that county
commissioner or whatever it was elected
right and and so that's the person that
is held accountable more than anything
else I think what's what's the structure
here so like with a cop who uh violates
an order or acts against people you know
maybe they get fired maybe they
themselves speak consequences but when
you move up the change who's holding
them accountable I think that's the
challenging part of this well what I'm
saying is some somebody is giving the
order and ultimately that is the person
that is most accountable no absolutely
not yes of course the person taking the
actions most accountable the person who
incites or instructs has some
accountability but it is these
individual officers look I at some point
that they're like you can't tell me I
mean that's that's like in the military
at some point that the job of the of the
person who executes the order if it is a
lawful order their job is to execute it
somebody at the top gave that order
that's the person and it's also the law
that if they are given an unlawful order
they must disobey it I feel like we all
need to watch A Few Good Men that's
really what this is coming down to is
telling police officers to to ignore the
law a lawful order but that's that and
again my point is or and again I don't I
think in each circumstance and I I do
the Supreme Court one I I agree with you
like that that's I mean in terms of the
law as I read it was very clear about
both in terms of the the federal statute
the U.S code and there's actually a
Virginia misdemeanor uh law that's on
the books in terms of for the for the
justices that live in Virginia
but on the other ones I don't know what
the town ordinance were and blah blah
blah but because I think in each case
there isn't a a difference what what
those Town ordinances were but it is the
elected officials ultimate response
person that is ultimately responsible so
the reason why
um
this country has the degree of stability
it has which is also in Decay it's
specifically because of police
I've heard so many stories and I've
experienced this uh I remember a great
story I was told where uh I don't know
if it was a public story so I should
probably keep some of it vague but
driving and speeding in Russia an
individual told me that they got pulled
over and the cop just you know rubs his
fingers together and they say
here you go and the cop says have a good
day right and then he says actually if I
give you extra well you pull this guy
behind me over and he goes sure
that's corruption what these officers
are engaged in is abject corruption so
they're saying I will not take any
responsibility for the actions for that
that I take I will not take any
responsibility for the instructions
given it's always someone else's fault
which means these officers are only
working for their own personal uh uh
gain and this means let me finish this
if each individual officer said I will
uphold the Constitution
and you give me an instruction that's
bad I will defy it then we would have
the most secure and protected culture in
in this country you'd have cops saying
I'm not going to unjustly arrest someone
you'd have cops saying I am not going to
ignore the law to benefit a politician
but you look at what's happening in New
York for instance the city illegally
seizes taxpayer dollars to spray to to
paint black lives matter in front of
Trump Tower as a political statement and
then gets 27 NYPD to protect it and
those cops say you got it that's aiding
and abetting a crime but they don't care
so long as we keep making excuses for
cops and saying it's not the cop's fault
it's the person instructed okay I'm
sorry I I look I will just say this at
the end of the day if if you're a cop in
a city official comes in and says I am
telling you that as the the legal
counsel for the city this is a lawful
order your job isn't to be to interpret
the law
their job is to to your point I agree
with you in the sense that their job is
your job is to it is to interpret the
light is no it isn't it's to enforce the
law so when if they are told that that
this is a lawful order what's what's an
improper lane change when you cross over
the yellow line or the white line
depending I mean a cop has to interpret
your action as unlawful
no he doesn't the law is Crystal Clear I
mean in terms of it's written down and
it says if you don't put a blinker on
and I mean it's actually written down
and the cop could argue so this is
actually something funny that comes up
in Chicago
slamming your brakes on a yellow light's
illegal you get pulled over for it's
it's it's uh Reckless it's uh abrupt
stopping they call it a police officer
has to interpret your action as crossing
the line what if you go through a yellow
light right at the last second and the
cop says I think it was red
the cop has to make the ultimate
decision themselves whether to pull you
over and and criminally cite you you can
go to a court you can ask a judge but
the police officer makes the termination
I have been in too many circumstances
where there have been there's been clear
evidence of crimes committed against me
and the cops say look we're not going to
pursue this it's a waste of our time the
police officer choosing how to interpret
the law so these officers should be
enforcing it and what's happening now is
too many people as like the left just
wants to destroy policing which is
insane but too many people on the right
excuse bad policing this is the erosion
I just I I look I think there's a
there's a difference and I get that
there are difference between we've all
had or not everyone but a lot of us have
traffic infractions where the cop comes
up and says look I get it you know or
hey we even ask them sometimes hey I was
in a hurry this was it can you give me a
little latitude on this there's a big
difference between that and something
where maybe they did ask and again I
don't look I know too many cops that put
their life on the line every day and
maybe they did push back and say I don't
agree with you on this and a legal
counsel comes in and says I'm sorry this
is what we interpret the laws huh I quit
Okay and maybe they should have or
should have but who knows I don't yeah
I I know too many of these guys that put
their life on the line so that you know
and you know what as a guy that has
dealt with enough threats I know too
many of these guys that have said I'll
walk through that door and I'll do I'll
be there for you you know what
they're they're in forces for the cult
they they are what's stopping us from
ending the corruption these officers
specifically in this image Are the
officers who are enforcing the
corruption of the machine when far left
extremists plan violent actions these
COPS stand down when when a bunch of
bumbling goddards walk through a door at
the Capitol Building these people hunt
them down so I am not giving them any
Grace none you think they have a uh like
a righteous justification to arrest
their commanding officer if they're
given an illegal order
I I think look it depends on the
situation again I would say this I my I
I will go I know too many of these guys
that
wake up every day
putting their life on the line
to uh to save innocent lives look at the
guys in in Nashville this week Michael
Collazo and Rex Engelbert yeah those
guys they they woke up they didn't need
someone to tell them what the law was
they woke up and said we're going to
save lives today and you know what I
need more of those guys every day that
say I'll go do what it takes to save
kids meanwhile someone showed up at
Brett Kavanaugh's house intending to
kill and kidnap his family and these
cops are like well you know we're
instructed not to arrest these
extremists so we won't and and here's my
point Tim I don't know what they were
told they arrested though right I'm
talking about the other people who are
outside illegally right and again but
but I don't presume that that that's how
that went down and maybe you're right
but but my point is is that for all I
know those six guys said BS
I'm pushing back on you and I'm gonna
fight every day and call my union rep
and say that this is ridiculous and I'm
gonna resign or I want to be re uh
reassigned on this but I I just I I
I I and I hold the guys that told them
not to do their job more accountable I
just watched I watched that video so
long ago of the cops showing up to some
guy's house going into his home and
arresting him when a violent mob showed
up in front of his house creating a very
visible imminent threat to his his life
they had burnt they'd set fire to
another building previously and the cops
go to his house and they arrest him
listen I I watched when I was downtown
and I'm watching the BLM stuff go down
there are days when I watched stuff
happen and I'm going are you kidding me
this person is literally committing a
crime I'm watching people get hit
nothing is happening so there are
instances where I'm I'm watching this
stuff happen but I hold the elected
officials in this city and around
America accountable for saying this is
because they're do
a commanding officer a superior officer
for these police said
listen from now on when you pull someone
over give them and give them an
opportunity to pay their traffic ticket
in cash and then bring that cash back to
me and we'll take care of it for you
they go okay you got a boss
or would we be like yeah that's that's
not you can't do that well hold on he's
not saying take bribe saying pay there
fine he's not telling cops to give fake
tickets he's saying let let the
individual pay the fine immediately in
cash if they do break the law
then what are we going to tolerate that
no then you get the commanding officer
on video saying it and you expose them
with something like project Veritas
that's what should be happening so we
are having it exposed right now that
these officers were instructed not to
arrest people in clear violation of the
law it's obviously political while this
is happening pro-life activists are
having cops kick their doors in and
arrest them we're seeing the enforcement
of red flag laws we saw a woman who was
wrongly raided by feds in Alaska because
she looked like someone who is inside
the capitol she happened to have been in
DC but she didn't go in the building or
or break any laws they still kick her
Dorne and rate her house so these cops
have no problem doing that they have no
problem shutting down churches I I think
that to me is like the most egregious
thing because here we have a clear we
have an oath to uphold the Constitution
the right to peace peaceably assemble
and practice your religion shall not be
infringed it is the first amendment and
across this country police officers with
smiles on their faces locked down
churches now I get it any violation of
free speech or right to practice is
wrong but isn't that very obvious to you
these guys are responsible for doing it
I don't care who instructed it it's this
guy who shows up to to to your church
who put a padlock on it or when they
when they padlocked Parts
again I think there's a big difference
if a local official if an elected
official or an unelected official says
the new city ordinance 126 says all
churches shall be closed here's the
ordinance
go do it that's a lawful order the cop's
job is not yes it is the Constitution is
a supreme level okay but but my point
Tim is that if a judge okays it or
whatever the cop doesn't is not the
cop's job is to execute orders
it's not the cop's job to pull the
Constitution yes how can you uphold the
Constitution when you're barring
Church's doors look do I did I I
literally when was appalled I agree with
you I did not think a single church
should ever be closed this is abort to
me but my point is that we're holding
the wrong people accountable
so the guy who literally shut the church
down isn't accountable
hold the Constitution violate it that's
you but it's not they don't get to call
balls and Strikes they don't get to
decide this is not that's not their job
well like how do you uphold the
Constitution because
every cop how many cops are there in
every city they don't get to go around
interpreting it that's not the job of a
cop so if you swear an oath to uphold
the Constitution first every military
officer every single officer swears an
oath
they don't get to decide what what it's
yes no they actually say it the the oath
says that they have to obey lawful
orders they don't get to interpret them
and how can it be lawful if it violates
the Constitution outright but
but that the point is is that that's
what counts legal counsel does is they
say that's a legal order and then what I
would say because I'm not a cowardice I
will not follow that order and I will
take legal counsel to court and ask a
judge first get someone else to do it or
I'll quit
okay well unfortunately if we don't have
then then we don't have a system of laws
then no actually we don't have a system
of law because cops won't follow the law
but if ever I don't disagree with with
again you and I are on the same team in
terms of where the outcome should be but
what I'm saying is if every single cop
is going to say great you know what I'm
going to just start going to to opposing
every order I get because maybe five
cups
because if a cop says Hey Elise should
not shut down churches is a simple and
finite granular point to be made
that one was obvious and the police
enforced it those are bad cops who
should be criminally charged in my
opinion for constitutional violations
end of story I'm thinking about
suspension of habeas corpus and how it's
happened a few times or at least Abe
Lincoln did it uh and then like you'd be
this would be a conversation we'd be
having about Abe Lincoln suspending
habeas corpus for the Civil War if he
hadn't done it you could argue they
wouldn't have won the Civil War uh
I I think what he that was specifically
a corridor going from DC uh up up to
Philly because Maryland was a slave
state and there was concerns about
sympathies in Maryland Maryland was like
one-third sympathetic to to the South so
not only did he suspend habeas corpus
going up to this Corridor he actually
had a bunch of State reps delegates
arrested I mean yeah the the dude I'm
exigent circumstances call it whatever
you want but the Civil War was nuts and
they called covet in exigent
circumstance obviously what I'm what I'm
seeing here is
if individual officers keep playing this
game of it's not my fault sorry I was
told to do it then we don't have a
system of laws because we have corrupt
politicians and cowards everywhere
because Bill de Blasio broke the law
stealing taxpayer dollars to paint a
political message in front of Trump
Tower and the police said look I'm just
going to protect it because I was told
to do so it's like okay well yo if the
mayor goes and Robs a Bank and you stand
there protecting him as he does it you
are a bank robber but that's a crime so
is so so look shutting down a church is
a crime right but wait you don't have
the right to kidnap people and shut down
their churches it violates ever like the
core tenants of this nation the founding
of freedom of religion and the right to
peaceably assemble we have laws
protected I agree with you on that I I'm
not look again I'm with you on that this
it's just this is the corruption of
American civilization of American
society and this nation that police no
longer have moral standards don't know
don't care and and our politicians don't
either and so the politicians say if I
get an office I can give
unconstitutional orders to police I will
never be held accountable and neither
will the police that's where we are
right now based on this Logic the only
solution is to tell these cops you know
what when I'm in power I'm going to make
sure you feel it down here's the point
what who's if the they is who I'm saying
hold accountable but that's impossible
it it's not because you're saying your
whole point is when the they is in power
my point is then that's who you should
be holding accountable I don't know I
don't everybody you can't eat cups no no
but you're saying when when you or who
this theoretical person gets in power
you hold the cops accountable no always
the cops accountable but but my point is
in order to hold the card the cops
accountable you have to be in power
right so that person is the person
that's that's causing the problem
whoever that yeah I think it's an
interesting point like if you have a cop
who shouldn't have shut down a church
who do you where do you take them to
right do you take them to their
commanding officer who as you're
pointing out that's what I'm saying we
need politicians to make sure each and
every one of these officers feels the
ticket though get the politician who's
doing it is the person to blame well who
is it that makes literally no sense I'm
sorry it just doesn't make sense I I
kind of
lady punches her in the face I'm not
gonna say who told you to do that
but you're saying that we need
politicians who will do this right who
will hold cops accountable my point is
there is a cop that's telling the pot a
politician that's telling the cop to to
shut down a church right okay okay so
hold that politician accountable and
then when you get an office you go to
those cops and you strip them of their
pensions and and hope they get on their
knees and beg and cry and you say I
don't care you're a bad person you are
evil and you are plaguing this country
so who's the politician that's
accountable for this who did this
so mayor Garland said he didn't know
this is something I want to bring up
because Matt Gates just was was grilling
or talking to Millie General Millie and
talking about all these trans uh or or
drag shows on military bases and Millie
was like I didn't know about that four
of them I had no idea send me that data
really really Mark you didn't know you
didn't know in your military that that
was happening yeah well I have no idea
so that so so mayor Carl you had no idea
had no idea that that was an issue
really this this deniability thing's
insane James Clapper you had no idea
they were spying on Americans none it's
always said before either they're
incompetent or they're lying and neither
one is a good look can you arrest people
for incompetence like if if a violated
law is given out and enforced in a guy's
system is the guy at the very top
responsible for not knowing can I get
back to to the point that you're getting
at right so there is a Supreme Court
police force
when this all went down Garland assigned
U.S Marshals to protect these guys so he
CR he took an action he assigned U.S
Marshals to protect the justices
then Katie Britt says today hey these
justices I mean these Marshals were told
not to do anything
and Garland says I didn't know anything
about it but you're the guy who's
assigned the marshals in the first place
they wouldn't have been doing the action
in the first place if you Garland hadn't
assigned them so
Garland just basically I I'm the one who
made them go there but then I had no
idea what they were doing that makes no
sense if just the simple point is
these bad things only happen because
human beings do them
it doesn't matter who the boss is like
when the banks fail we don't arrest the
people at the top of the banks right
what ends up happening is some like
senior VP guy who signed off on
something ends up getting fined or
something like that there's always an
excuse to protect the people in power
when when it comes down to it and
because there's no actual mechanism
because because I think a large portion
of police officers are cowardly and
corrupt there's never going to be any
law enforcement action against corrupt
officials and then what happens is
regardless of who gets into Power
they're happy to have a Mindless
Force who will do whatever they're told
they all are there's a bit there's a
lawsuit in New York apparently they
won't hire uh police officers who have
IQs above a certain number and the
argument they made was well they get
bored and they quit so we want stupid
people well because stupid people don't
know what the law is and don't question
just do as they're told that's a problem
this is what's corrupting this country
if every police officer had Scruples
then you would have these drag shows
being shut down they're already illegal
you would not have of at these Pride
events for instance where as long as
I've known about them people dance
around naked and engage in overtly
illegal obscene behavior in public but
police are like I'm not getting involved
in that because they're cowards because
they're cowards who don't care about
their Community because big cities have
become just corrupt wastelands crime is
skyrocketing for these reasons and Luke
gradkowski pointed this out he
interviewed a guy there was a guy who
started stabbing people on a train and
the cops said I'm not getting involved
because the cops are corrupt they're not
there's they're under no obligation to
intervene to protect you and they follow
unjust and unconstitutional orders all
the time I'm done we need someone who
gets into office and the first thing
they do is they line up all the cops if
you're the president it's going to be
the federal productive service it's
going to be ice going to be CBP and
they're going to look them all in the
eyes and say if you break the law or
refuse to uphold the Constitution I will
make sure you feel it to your bones you
will lose your pension you will lose
your job and you will never work again
mark my words and if you want to quit
now quit but the problem is politicians
enjoy the fact that cops will do
whatever they're told because they know
that people like you Sean will say it's
not the cop's fault and that gives them
carte blanche to do things like this
there should be no circumstance where
the far left is allowed to Rampage
through cities smashing Windows setting
fires setting up the Chas setting up the
the the George Floyd autonomous Zone
setting up the Atlanta autonomous Zone
but the cops don't do anything about it
and the politicians aren't being held
accountable because in Democrat cities
for instance who's going to hold them
accountable in Chicago it's been
Democrat rule for 100 years so as long
as these cops are good little foot
soldiers they never have anything to
worry about and that's why you end up
with so much corruption in Chicago
that's what's going to happen to the
rest of this country it's going to
happen in the rural areas and it's
already happening because these cops are
like look boss told me how to enforce
the law I ain't gonna do it okay then
the far left are allowed to Rampage and
set fires create autonomous zones
literally murder people and and they
keep doing it Aaron Danielson took two
to the chest sure don't get me wrong
Barr hunted that guy down and killed him
because there's there is still a line
but because the law enforcement against
the far left has been so LAX and
outright protected like when Kamala
Harris and Joe Biden's staff donated to
bail these people out they are
encouraged to do more of it knowing like
I mentioned with the inauguration of
trump 200 and some odd far left
extremists who were rampaging through DC
setting cars on fire setting fires on
the street and smashing Windows actually
won and the city had to pay them
meanwhile when these same extremists
show up to Justice's homes Merrick
Garland says protect them and the cops
go you got it buddy we'll make sure
they're nice and protected I'm thinking
about like in the in an effort to stay
idealistic like if you gut all the
entire police force because they served
the Nazis or whatever then you have no
more German police like after the
leadership I'm kind of understanding
what you're saying Sean I kind of with
you about blame the commander you you
remove command and you put in a just
commander and then the soldiers will
immediately follow the just command and
they they don't care if it's just or
unjust they're just there to serve the
commander not really truly they're there
to serve the greatness of humanity or
whatever it is but in in the chaos of
War you serve your commander first
unless they're crazy and then you serve
you know the men first but I I'm I'm
concerned about what Merrick Garland did
because either this is this is
ineptitude and he didn't know what his
Department was doing or he issued this
order to stand down but I'll give you
one and again I don't mean to I I look
at
the guys down at the border patrol if
you remember the the guys that the the
horse Patrol that got whatever I've had
Tom Holmen and I've talked to a couple
of these guys right these guys who did
the right thing do you know their lives
are destroyed right
so many of these cops that I've talked
to and I'm not ex like we're getting off
on I think but
there are cops that go out there and do
the right thing their lives get
destroyed and they get told you arrest
that guy you arrest that person because
they did that we're gonna let them out
they that no one has their back anymore
in this country so I and I I'm not
saying that it's perfect but I'm telling
you that in this city you walk down the
street you ask guys that are cops they
watch that crime they go hey go Reseka
you go you know what they're gonna do
they're going to take them they're going
to bring them down they're going to let
them ride out and the cop goes so what
do you want me to do I'm going to get to
your point they get oh you know what
you're going to get arrested you're
going to get sued because you did this
and now you're personally liable we're
gonna come after you personally for
doing this in the cups like yeah well
cops have uh what's it called
qualified qualified immunity so tell me
how much that helps them when they're I
mean I'm just saying that like a left
will destroy their lives and the right
does nothing but excuse them so I'm just
I'm I'm not interested the the the
watching these cops shut down churches I
was just like how is that possible how
is it I thought cops were like more
conservative I watched a video of antifa
attack a guy and the cops arrested the
victim because they were scared what
antifa would do and they apologized to
antifa I saw a video where a guy in his
own home was arrested by the place as
BLM cheered for the police I thought
they hated the police no they don't want
to defund them they want to replace them
with loyal forces who will do what they
say and it's working
we we watch with the Merrick Garland
incident far left extremists have
battered police into absolute submission
and that's why these cops need to be
held accountable these cops need to fear
the law enforcement more than they fear
far-left extremists they need to say to
themselves look man if I don't arrest
that guy I'm gonna lose my pension I
have to arrest him it's the law right
now it's the opposite right now they're
going if I enforce the law against the
people who control the reins of politics
they're going to come after me I better
just do nothing okay well that's a
corrupt cop in my opinion they are
sacrificing this country for personal
gain God get rid of them gotta fire em
got to strip them over their pensions
that's the only thing they'll understand
because right now the path of least
resistance for these cops is to be
corrupt and to support corrupt
politicians because that's the that's
it's easier it's it's safer for them you
can also I want to make sure it's harder
for them you can reward them for doing
the right thing that that'd be like an
instance of punishing them for doing the
wrong thing and then additionally like
you saying guys get their lives
destroyed their livelihoods destroyed
what would be a way to help them
again I feel like we're going we're way
down a rabbit hole but but I I still
don't understand this because if a cop
goes out and arrests everyone and the
mayor of the city says I'm going to let
everyone out the second you arrest them
and then he goes and I'll arrest them
again
okay and the mayor lets him out again
that at some point you need to get the
politicians who are creating the system
and change them if you don't get those
people out the system doesn't change but
who said anything about not doing that I
literally said we need a politician
who's going to go in that's what I but
that's why I'm saying we actually agree
on that part right and then once they're
in they go to each individual cop who
support cops are just responding to that
uh the the police officers as
individuals need to understand they will
be held responsible as individuals so we
need a politician who gets in and the
first thing he does is he goes to the
corrupt officer that made illegal
arrests and defended far left extremists
and say you're a collaborator and you're
lucky we don't criminally charge you you
are being stripped of your badge
stripped of your weapon stripped of your
pension go home you will never work in
law enforcement again
these cops that are defending corrupt
politicians are the are the henchmen of
evil evil people
so we need a position to go in and then
start reviewing which one of these
officers is corrupt I mean Chicago is is
a hell Zone there's a video of a cop
there was an instant where a cop parked
illegally and a meter maid gave him a
ticket so we went outside grabbed her by
the throat and slammed her and lifted
her up by her neck screaming at her
because the cops in Chicago are dirty as
they come they operate black sites where
they kidnap people and torture them
there was a famous story of the of the
guy who was cattle prodding
electrocuting people into false
confessions because these cops never get
held accountable and I like the the
police departments Suburban Place
apartments that are smaller tend to be
pretty good but you're getting these big
cities they're bad you get in areas like
DC they're bad someone needs to make
sure we get rid of the corrupt cops and
create an institution of good cops but
but you you realize what you just said
all of these cities are controlled by by
left Democrats that have been controlled
by democrats forever Chicago D.C they're
all controlled by democrats and so as
long as the they're all responsive to a
system now you get it the police
officers are enforcers for corrupt
politicians if there were no police the
politicians would be able to do nothing
they could as it is it is plainly an
obvious logic a politician who goes
outside and issues an order that is not
followed has no power none but when you
have corrupt police officers that say
yes sir we'll do whatever you say then
you have the problem getting rid of that
corrupt politician doesn't change the
fact you have a corrupt police
enforcement because the next polish that
gets in in these cities in Chicago or
New York will be as corrupt and the
corrupt police will enforce the corrupt
actions but if you get rid of the
officers and enforce it at the
individual level
who's going to get rid of them
if the politician I mean if if well that
that's a different entirely different
argument the fact is the only way you
stop the corruption is to root it out
you know cutting the top of the weed off
doesn't get rid of the weeds you got to
pull by The Roots one thing concerns me
if you remove all the officers at the
bottom that the corrupt uh politicians
would hire mercenaries to do their job
so just getting rid of what looks like
one problem doesn't necessarily mean the
problem is going to go away
in some ways it could get worse right
because then you have settled drawn A
Line in the Sand over who is willing to
work with this police commissioner or
whatever the next it may be and you're
not saying you know who's going to fill
them right like I feel like at this
point
you're saying either you take everyone
out all at once or the there's a chance
for the problem to Fester as we try and
sort of sift through this right the
issue may be that there is no way to
stop the corruption because these cities
will keep electing the same people who
then have law enforcement who keep doing
exactly as they're told regardless of
what's legal or not but but the point is
the Mayors the governors have no power
without the men and women in uniform to
enforce their decrees
so to act like a corrupt
a large group of corrupt individuals or
mostly corrupt not all of them I don't
think all of them are but a lot of them
especially a lot of superiors willing to
take political action instead of just
action so long as they exist you can
never stop the corrupt politicians but a
corrupt politician without law
enforcement to do their bidding has no
power at all they can go outside and say
we're gonna if if the cops refused to
listen to Merrick Garland and said we're
going to arrest them if they break the
law
then Merrick garland would stomp his
feet and be like but but I'm Merrick
Garland it's like it's illegal to
protest in front of a supreme court
Justice's home nothing you say will
change that get Congress to change the
law but for the time being we enforce
the laws it's written Merrick garland
would just cry about it instead they let
Merrick Garland do these illegal things
unconstitutional things it's selectively
enforcing laws against conservatives and
ignoring the far left that I just I
agree with you on I mean in fact today
they were literally asking mayorkas
about that with respect to the Border
they literally said to him you have
the the border wall is an act of
Congress it was passed why are you not
building it and he obfuscated a bunch of
things I mean there are laws you either
follow them or you don't yeah well let's
go to super chats before we get started
make sure you smash that like button and
become a member at timcast.com because
we are going to have an uncensored
members only portion of the show goes
live about 10 10 p.m and we will select
a few callers who submit questions so if
you want to get instant access to the
VIP question submission chat room it's
25 bucks a month or if you've been a
member for at least six months I know I
said every time but we had to create
some kind of gate to keep out extremists
and activists who want to come and screw
with us so we did time and we did Money
options but we'll be taking calls from
you guys which will be a lot of fun but
for now we'll read your super chats
all right Shadow's hand says multiple
schools were called with shooting hoaxes
across the country today claiming that
there were shooting threats that were
going to happen my nieces school is one
of them no one is talking about this we
we did have that plan maybe we'll talk
about it in the uncensored portion yeah
these are the ones where the calls were
coming from foreign outside the United
States crazy right yeah it feels like
things are getting really weird and that
everyone can see where we're vulnerable
right yep I'm not your buddy guy says
that the devil had a cult tell me one
different thing to wokeness they
celebrate all seven deadly sins even
promote the mutilation of God's image
yeah I don't disagree with that it's
kind of weird right
I think if the devil had a cult he'd be
a rock star so watch out
what do you mean by that though Lucifer
you give me like a musician or do you
might be someone loves you know so not
Donald Trump be a social media
influencer big cultist on the internet
millions of followers on YouTube watch
out T-Rex Pet Shop says you can find us
on Public Square it's great vote with
your dollar and stop supporting woke pet
stores agreed
you know and you can find businesses
that do delivery and stuff too so even
if they're not in your area if you if
you need something like if you need a
pet food or any pet store T-Rex Pet Shop
go on Public Square app look around for
businesses and you can order from them
if you're going to order anything let's
let's build up that parallel economy and
you can also go to castbrew.com and buy
coffee from us
all right
Steve O says Sean was it difficult
working on the Avengers set as agent
coulson's stunt double
but seriously keep speaking out in every
way possible has anyone ever said that
to you before no
no all right
Max Redick says can we talk about David
packman this guy is losing it I used to
listen to him to see what the left
thinks and is saying about current
issues but he constantly straw mans
conservative arguments
don't they all
I was him in particular maybe I don't
know I think I mean
yeah of course I really try not to
insult David Pacman but the last couple
days he said some really stupid stuff
about or he said one tweet in particular
that was really really vicious yeah and
I you know he's a bit you know David I
feel like you know you know how to put
on a suit you know how to set up a
studio but like are you really doing
like what are you doing
you saw what he tweeted I this is the
one that Don responded is that the the
one that Don Jr responded to he might
have he said something like perhaps this
happened because there weren't thoughts
yeah yeah yeah Don responded to it and
then he responded to yeah so I yeah uh I
mean yes I was one of those ones where
you just sitted out but he deleted the
Tweet correct and then he claimed that
it was because he was getting
anti-semitic attacks and death threats
and then he deleted that one too because
people were like no dude this ain't it
like the left was coming at him they
were like bro what is wrong with you
like yeah he made this fake argument
he's like the right says these shootings
are happening because they took prayer
out of school so I'm like no they're not
they've been saying it's mental health
issues and gun-free zones right so he's
making fake arguments up and then
arguing against them especially with
this school in particular they probably
didn't take prayer out of the right
Church Christian School that's run by
the church this point was nonsense all
right perturbed alpaca says we are in
Spain in the 30s we will break out into
a multi-front multi-factional Civil War
and the new superpowers will send
volunteers to test the emerging
weaponized drone and AI Technologies I
don't disagree people should watch I
watched a documentary on the Spanish
Civil War and the similarities are
terrifying
people don't understand because
they think Civil War is like the
American Civil War but in the American
Civil War Virginia was a sovereign state
functioned within its own government you
know Tennessee was its own state New
York was its own State and so it was a
bunch of different countries it was more
akin to like a a a like a war like World
War one with all these different
countries fighting each other we called
it World War but it was like mostly
Europe that's what the Civil War was
more like actual Civil Wars throughout
history have been
you know people post photos of the
United States where it's like here's the
blue areas and here's the red areas how
could there be a Civil War and I'm like
that map looks like every Civil War map
outside of the United States
like yes the urban centers become one
faction the rural areas are another
faction and then they fight and the
rural factions always win surprise the
people who know how to survive in the
wilderness tend to be able to defeat
people who can't grow food
live in a building that they wanted to
be like perfectly separated like the
people over here don't like each other
and then they're just gonna randomly
like that would make it so you didn't
have a civil war because they could
leave each other alone right
balkanization
all right John Curson says Tim not sure
if it hit your radar but schools
Statewide and Pa got robocalls saying
there was an active shooter causing
massive responses something to look into
is happening all over the country
apparently crazy
all right
hillbillary Clinton says is a perfect
example of why we need to stop blaming
guns and start blaming people that are
mentally ill the mainstream media will
never do that though especially when a
trans person is to blame
yep but the mainstream media doesn't
look at transgender as transgenderism as
a mental illness the same way they would
regard schizophrenia or uh you know
something else as mental illness by the
way you notice in any of these stories
that I I noticed it this morning that
that was not I can't say I saw every
story right by any means but it was
amazing how that literally didn't even
come up the the transgender issue it was
almost like they didn't want most people
I mean we talked about this earlier in
terms of you know the the how many
Independents that it was like the NBCS
the ABCs the the cbs's in the Washington
Post and again I'm not I didn't can't
speak for every one of those but I saw a
few of them almost didn't want you to
know the
whatever the genderism of of the shooter
they they wanted they just sort of said
the shooter do you see what reuter said
no former Christian Student
shoots up school or whatever but there
was the AP story today where they said
uh that this is uh the the
headmistress uh they said in a male
dominated industry like it's it was a
religious school and they were like this
isn't like like an industry I mean it
was it's that they go to lengths
to just change the narrative because it
goes against what they want people to
think about something that the goods
counter to to all of the that they don't
want anything to go against this whole
theory that that somehow it could you
know it's not that's a bunch of right
wing crazy nut job yeah actually the
fact that she was at a Christian School
that's right that's what made this
happen but that was her second target
like the first Target she went to was
locked down by some sort of security so
she couldn't was what was the first
Target I don't even know was it not a
Christian I think it was a mall so so I
I believe then it wasn't targeted it
wasn't like she was gone the cop said
that based on what they learned it was a
targeted attack at the school even
though she went to the mall she yeah
maybe she want maybe she had two
different targets in mind for two
different reasons but this one was
definitely targeted at least that's what
the police maps and everything yeah but
the point is is that I just find it
interesting and this goes back to what I
was saying earlier about the Biden stuff
right that they cut out he makes
inappropriate jokes and that's being
kind
and they cut out the narrative because
they don't want you to see that and then
they don't report on this part of it of
the shooter because they don't want you
to see that they want to perpetrate a
narrative about who this person is who
the bad guy is who the good guy is why
the shooter is now a victim because
we've got to make sure that this all
falls in line with who the good people
are and who the bad people are
all right Martin Edgar says the biggest
problem is if conservatives protest or
complain they're called domestic
terrorists by the administration the
media and the left and the doj when the
left does the same they are victims of
Oppression
which is why the most important thing
you can do is have a family make money
no joke then in 10 or 20 years you will
have well-adjusted intelligent capable
children who make money and control
industry and then the far left weirdos
will be crying about it and begging
government to steal it from you but you
will have more power more access that's
how you win this thing I mean look move
out of the Cities get some chickens get
some goats have a family make some money
learn get in shape start exercising all
of these things will make you stronger
and more powerful and if that Trend
continues for 20 years the woke far left
weirdos will be left with nothing
because they're not having kids you're
not going to be in their schools your
kids won't be in their schools they will
eventually cease to exist you know
something protect your mind from a
cynicism too like if you find yourself
thinking well they're just going to do
it anyway like that's the you lose they
will do it if you do if you think that
but if you have faith that's the
antidote to cynicism so have faith
all right
David Toronto says it's not about not
all about age it's about Democrats they
are all crazy look at our government
they they are gen Z they are older sorry
but Dems are loons well yeah they they
attract each other and I think prominent
Democrats are smarter and they're more
like pied Pipers who are empowered by
zombie hordes yeah and and all Democrats
move
they're saying right like at one point
wasn't Hillary Clinton against gay
marriage I mean they they changed she
wasn't 2016. I'm pretty sure yeah like a
league demo came out or something
yeah and Biden was against all I mean
like again they they drifted to catch
the upcoming voter class
well just though they don't even if
they'll go wherever the wherever they
have to I mean drifting farther exactly
all right son of a Murph says make
family dinners great again agreed and I
gotta tell you man
uh you know you may notice Ben Shapiro
is not online Friday evenings
throughout through Saturday because of
Shabbat and this is a tremendous
Advantage for the Jewish community in
that once a week their family comes
together disconnects from all the BS
talks to each other reinforcing
Community you have the strength of the
family unit and then when they go to
church synagogue or whatever it's
referred to like when they go to
religious that's when their Community
when the families then come together and
have that convergence
that is is the stem is the root of the
flower
for most of us in this country that's
been cut off we don't have family
dinners and we don't go to church so
we're not convening with our own
families and then we're not convening
with our community that's something
people need to pay attention to which is
why we want to do Saturday morning
cartoons the new Cafe where we have
families come in bring their kids the
kids can hang out watch approved
educational cartoons we'll have pancake
sausage maybe not some we'll have to do
pancakes but I'm not I'm not big on the
sugar stuff right but but some people
might be so we'll get we'll make eggs
with our chickens farm fresh chicken
City eggs and all that and then families
can hang out build community communal
bonds and I think that is a key to
winning the culture War then we'll open
in 10 years we'll have 50 locations and
all across the country people will come
and hang out for Saturday morning
cartoons
that's how we do it I always had a
billion dollars y'all if I was uh I
don't even know if you need a billion
dollars for it if I was making as much
as Joe Rogan was I'd hire a guy and be
like start setting up coffee shops all
over the country to do this
so maybe maybe five years of other
resources yeah this one's profitable
then you could probably raise that money
immediately
that's the thing too like maybe
investment is the is the real path
forward we we are about the estimate is
two months till operability for the
coffee shop
but we got to do the second floor the
third floor and there's a lot of permits
and stuff it'll probably be a little bit
longer but um my family has experience
with opening cafes before so based on
everything we've gone through it may be
two months
once we have this built
I'm fairly confident that we could
easily get a substantial investment to
spring up a bunch of these locations in
in major in major areas correct
Community you know hang out kind of
places so create some cool recipes for
breakfast almond flour pancakes with a
little maple syrup lower sugar content
the cartoons to be done by Freedom Tunes
I want him to make a specific children
Saturday morning real well the idea is
Saturday mornings it'll be like you know
daily wires got chip Chilla so we'll
we'll play whatever content they allow
us but I don't want to you know if
they're cool with us playing their
cartoons in these PL in these venues
then absolutely and maybe older cartoons
that are just funny Tom and Jerry I mean
Bugs Bunny is a little bit empty right
it was a little violent that's what I
was not so much I don't care about the
violence it's like there's no real
message in it we want to we want a
positive message okay so your book
becomes a cartoon yeah I'm thinking hey
I'll do it Brave books
animate it dude yeah someone asked me of
the day if I read you know there is
there an audio version I'm like maybe
this is the way to to get into that we
can do the audio Yeah super stardom but
we could do we could do motion Stills
okay where you basically just show each
page slowly moving with a person
narrating the characters I like where
you're going with that and that's that's
a start but it's also about the adults
too it's about the parents coming and
meeting each other so we do these
community events and that's what you're
talking about getting to know your
neighbors right exactly I think that's
gonna that'll save this country and the
world and uh I'm pretty sure we know
enough people who'd be willing to invest
in that we just need to get this one up
and running then once we yeah we're
interviewing managers then that manager
we'll get to manage another location
somewhere else but we'll start popping
them up all over the place and the best
part is once we have like 5 000
locations it's going to be so awesome
when they try and pull another lockdown
and every single location refuses to
close they're gonna go uh oh this
massive Corporation is not abiding what
do we do it's like I don't know you
can't do anything about it
and then we'll uh we'll we'll win the
culture War all right let's read some
more
Cain Abel says Ian tolerance is what led
us here today this is why you should not
tolerate evil in any way or shape yeah I
know but tolerance also is what led us
to where we were 40 years ago or 30
years ago when we were like the greatest
cultural revolution on earth like really
with Hollywood and all this really thin
80s or no like 1920 30 40 50 60 like our
ability to tolerate religions of all
kinds Creeds of all kinds there was a
lot of problems but it was like one of
the better
tolerance systems on Earth
um but it get like that's a problem with
liberal democracies is they're easy to
infiltrate with bad ideas I think you
just gotta you know lack of if you can
let the ideas rise to the service a lot
of is like if you're stomping out good
ideas and just letting only letting the
bad ones rise that's all you're going to
see do you ever think that
in being
impressive and therefore don't say no to
things because aggressive tolerance is
one way to go because I feel like
tolerance with boundaries yeah like you
have to have you have to have structural
functional boundaries yeah of course
yeah uh
yes
well all right let's uh let's read some
more Super chats Raymond g Stanley Jr
says G is Tim today's episode is quite
enraging the truth of the situation is
that no one will save uh but us we must
stand up for ourselves you me the folks
are uh the folks watching are our only
way out of this
but I think it actually is really simple
and you know a lot of people are are
wondering what to do and it's like have
a family get out of the cities and make
money get the chickens yeah man be more
self-sufficient
allocate your money properly
I I I can I can hear Max Kaiser
screaming by Bitcoin move the El
Salvador I don't know about moving
outside the box wants me personally
though I think crypto is another venue
if everybody listen to this show
12 years ago bought Bitcoin
the culture War would be over
because you would have millions of
Bitcoin millionaires controlling
industry and snapping their fingers and
just doing whatever they want you know a
lot of tremendous influence a lot of
Bitcoin like Millionaires and
billionaires went to Puerto Rico three
or four years ago to turn it into like a
utopic 21st century to not pay taxes
because if you live in Puerto Rico
there's no income tax and I've heard
it's just been trashed like I haven't
been there there's a hurricane too that
decimated the island that God how's that
not still getting news what are you
going to say no that's why I didn't
realize that was the uh that was the
motivation
would they still be millionaires out is
that where Bitcoin is now so if you held
it and you still if I bought Bitcoin so
so first
if I had bought Bitcoin in 2011 when I
wanted to I'd have sold it when it hit
five bucks I was gonna buy it at 70
cents my friend convinced me not to do
it true story and uh shout out to Jeff
and uh you know he said no but I would
at five bucks I would have been like
that's a massive increase I'm taking the
couple Grand because I had no way of
knowing it would be at thirty thousand
dollars per coin but I would have uh
right now I think like 200 million
dollars if I had spent the FI I was
gonna buy I was gonna put five thousand
dollars into Bitcoin in 2011. back then
in order to buy it you had to email
random people and because there were no
there were no exchanges it was just some
weird thing on the internet right and so
and then someone would send it to your
address I actually had 20 Bitcoin that I
lost which is like half a million
dollars I think I used to play Oh I
played poker with the student he was
like you get Bitcoins I'm like I don't
know what is it he's like you got to
write it down here like a piece of paper
I was like no dude no it was 2011. I had
a computer I had about 20 20 Bitcoin on
it it got destroyed and I didn't care
because it was like 15 bucks now it's
half a million dollars oh my God oh my
gosh you know but it is what it is so
those coins are gone I think a lot of it
is is an example of how little faith
people have in the US dollar that's why
crypto is doing so well yep if so here's
the best part where Fiat I never spent
that five thousand dollars it was in my
savings right and since then I've only
saved more
so in my investment retirement or
whatever that money never got spent if I
had just taken it and put it in Bitcoin
at its peak Bitcoin hit about 60k I
would have been worth half a billion
are you much under crypto
I think you guys are the ones the last
time I was here
I I put a few grand I mean I think like
that I literally think that's when I
invested
the last time I think Luke forced me to
get in yeah he'll do that yeah and but
that's why I'm saying like I got in I I
think it's been influenced by your guest
yeah but I I I am I was very late to the
game clearly and that's why I'm trying
to figure out you know because I know
that I have not seen the huge uh returns
that yeah it's a for me I think of as a
form of insurance in case right yeah
it's nice and this is not I I by any
meat stretch of the Imagine I'd put it
up in there just so I could
be part of the experience
how's the experience not great that's
why I'm trying to figure out what you
know or I don't know I'm not not
physical I'm always saying hold that's
the thing I know that's what it's old
hold
so it's been a couple I mean I feel
that's true of the stock market too
people when you have to hold up so the
hold is like
you you you're supposed to periodically
or this is what they say every every
week or so often you put money into
Bitcoin like you you put a small
percentage in because it's it's where
you save a store of value and then like
with any investment you take only a
little bit out so you're putting more
and you're taking out but it's because
the value is increasing okay so this is
the theory I'm not talking anybody to do
anything I don't get financial advice
but I'll say this
um I invested in Bitcoin several years
ago and uh
you know it's like 20 times up I'll say
Max Kaiser and Stacy Herbert who are in
El Salvador which has adopted Bitcoin as
his National currency are like ex like
partying like it is like 1999 Prince
thought like they are it is like they
are on top of the world with joy every
day they live in joy well El Salvador's
crime rate has collapsed the standard of
living has skyrocketed what uh what the
president has done down there with
Bitcoin has revolutionized this country
for the better and now people want to
live there because I think they're
saying not as the lowest crime in
Central America it used to have some of
the highest crime and then the media got
mad they started arresting all these
cartel and gang members I'm like dude he
is revolutionizing that country for the
better and I'm like you know Luke is
telling me to get property down there to
create like a hub so we can go down
periodically and I'm like does Luke have
property and not a bad idea you know
it's getting expensive though because
because now everybody's it's getting
it's getting nice the words El Salvador
translates to the savior wow
is that really what that means yeah the
Savior whoa I think we gotta set up like
a Chromecast the same thing the Savior
either get like an office down there and
set up a studio so we can periodically
go down and do shows be cool yeah yeah
February down there or something
yeah the satellite office
I think it'd be great we need to be in
the sun we'll be like Tim I've got to
move to the satellite office for a
couple weeks
I mean that's fine a couple weeks
and starts just commuting let's go
surfing all right Phuket Freddy says Tim
is 100 right click the rant just read
ordinary Men by Christopher Browning
right on
all right what do we got here Viking
vets is a viking vet says there's a
famous movie about about this unlawful
orders Jack Nicholson Tom Cruise A Few
Good Men that's right moral and ethical
actions against orders used to be valued
and we believed was Duty what happened
to that
um it became every man for himself
no one no one uh look Luke made a video
a decade ago where he's like every day
millions of people get on the subway and
none of them ever talk to each other so
I decided to talk to them it's like this
really heartfelt video where he asked
people questions but he's right if you
lived in New York you totally get it you
don't know who your next door neighbor
is
everyone is isolated from each other
that's what happened so when what they
end up doing now what they end up uh
what they do
if they want to arrest a gym owner they
know local cops will not do it because
the cops have to use that gym or the
cops know people who who know them
they'll find cops from a city you know
one town over bring them in to enforce
unjust laws because these cops are like
I'm never coming back here
that's sad reality
all right let's read some more
Noob actual says I cannot stand
politicians we need to actually we need
more civil servants who hate the
position they're in but no it's
necessary they are not better or more
important than anybody else yeah serve
the office not the person I think Matt
Gates is great I was watching him today
when you know he's talking about all
this stuff yeah and I'm just like I
wanted to message him today I I just
can't imagine doing a job where everyone
tries to destroy you I mean you too man
doing a job where they try to destroy
you they lie about you and you like
don't make money doing it you know what
I mean like what's the benefit other
than like someone's got to do this job
man you know
and and you know I know we were talking
about this before it starts like there
there's days when you have to in my job
in particular and in some of these other
ones too but where you can't say I mean
you're hamstruck you can't say anything
because your job is to serve right and
and that's the heart to some degree
that's the hardest part where you're
being attacked and you're not that
that's part of it isn't to defend
yourself because you're supposed to be
serving somebody else yeah I asked you
if you could say what you thought as
because someone was like Ian you should
be the speaker or the for Donald Trump
and I'm like haha well and then I'm like
can I say what I think can I be like nah
he was and Sean was like no no no no
that's not your job and that's right and
that's the hardest part because there
were days where
you would see something about yourself
and that your job is not to defend
yourself you're there to serve and speak
for somebody else and so how did you
stay motivated then
look I because I I found great honor to
have a position like that right to think
about it like I grew up in in a you know
we were talking about this before my dad
was a Salesman right the idea of like
being 60 feet from the Oval Office of
the United of the president United
States that's I mean unreal and so to
wake up every day and think I'm going
into the White House I'm serving the
president United States and the American
people is is a pretty awesome
responsibility uh and if you if that's
not enough of a motivation you're in the
wrong business
um so for me that's what did it but it's
tough every day when someone's in in a
lot of cases I remember there was this
one day where it says uh Politico tweets
out and it says Spicer is I think the
the phrase they used was like butt
Tweeting or something right and and the
problem was because there was this tweet
that came out from at press the problem
was they didn't look at the handle of
the of the the Twitter it was fake it
was yeah and again of course at press
Tech is the Press secretary's Twitter
handle and it's verified and whatever
but they hadn't they were in such a
hurry to announce you to denounce me and
this is why I wrote a book about fake
news uh you know a children's book is
because that's what it was like and
you're going and finally once I you know
called it out to the reporter instead of
apologizing they wrote apparently that
was it wasn't apparently no no you were
wrong yeah but it wasn't like we made a
mistake it was apparently there's
another handle and it was like like that
if you're making it up like or yeah it's
like as if they didn't make a mistake
but that's you had you had to eat it
every day because you can't make it
about you let's grab this one more Super
Chat American woman says our checks and
balances are broken cops won't arrest
DA's won't prosecute judges won't
enforce politicians lie and elections
are corrupt when every Avenue of Regis
is cut off what then Raz al Ghul I'm
sorry racial Al ghoul and um the league
of assassins
what about them well they decided the
solution was to put a hallucinogen
chemical into the water supply of Gotham
and then vaporize it so that they would
wipe the city out and then rebuild via
the Scarecrow
uh yes oh I see
but uh no none of that we just need
people to have families get some
chickens and make some money but dear
God also you don't want to force people
into desperation you make a good point
if you make a mockery of the system
people might get desperate and that is
not the way to go so we need to take
this system very seriously and the most
important thing anyone can do is smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com click the
join us button because we are going to
have a members only uncensored portion
of the show up on the website in about
10 minutes live and we're going to take
Collins from those of you who are
members who are in our Discord server
and have submitted so check that out you
can follow the show at timcastirl you
can follow me at timcast Shawn you want
to shout anything out uh again go to
bravebooks.com you can get the parents
go banana the Great Book for the next
few days that till the end of March you
can get it for one dollar no better deal
in the Biden economy than that
bravebooks.com and people can follow you
on Twitter too I want to point them too
as I think it's just that's John yeah
cool I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should go to
timcast.com click on the read tab see
all of the work from me Chris Bertman uh
all of our other journalists uh you can
follow at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram it's the best if you want to
follow me personally you can follow me
on Instagram at hannahclar.b and you can
follow me on Twitter at HC bromelo
thanks so much I'm Ian crosslandfall
meadiancrosslin.net and anywhere on
social media in Crossland this is a copy
of the parrot the Paris Go Bananas uh
Sean Spicer in Brave books art by Martin
Maron I hope I said your your name right
Martine is it just Martin
so if you guys want to get a copy
bravebooks.com thanks John thank you
uh and I am search.com that got kind of
heated didn't it it was good it was
great yeah it was fun yeah we'll see you
guys in the after show later
head over to timcast.com we'll see you
there